[Música]
[Aplausos]
alguém que gosta de pizza
eu adoro também não posso garantir para
vocês que até na guerra em tela entrega
de pizza vocês imaginem as bombas caindo
uma cidade em estado de sítio você pedir
uma pizza e receber assim terminou o meu
dia em 2006 na guerra entre israel eo
líbano
então meu dia terminou com pizza e
começou um tanque de guerra vindo na
minha direção
no norte de israel esse tanque ele dobra
à direita na verdade ele veio na minha
direção dobra à direita invadir aquela
plantação ali e de repente começam um
bombardeio lá de cima da montanha ou
regular começa a lançar foguetes
katyusha contra o tanque eo tanque
obviamente dispara contra as posições do
hizbollah eu olho estou na fronteira lá
em cima
bandeira do líbano eu aqui ali meu carro
branco bem discreto e a sensação que tu
tens durante 15 minutos e bombardeia de
que suas pernas tremem tu tem vontade de
atirar no chão mas ao mesmo tempo a
adrenalina que quer levar adiante a
seguir aquele tanque mas o medo que faz
ficar e na verdade a gente tá
eternamente na vida no jornalismo da
humanidade na fronteira entre iria ficar
entre a adrenalina eo medo meu dia
terminou eu contei para vocês mandando a
reportagem pizza e o dia então terminou
com uma ligação da minha mãe na qual ela
havia contado que o meu pai tinha ligado
para ela tinha ouvido o relato e eu
deveria imediatamente voltar a porto
alegre a ordem que eu tinha dado ele
tinha dado para ela ligar para o meu
chefe de volta para porto alegre
ele tinha medo que eu voltasse dentro de
um saco preto jornalistas tem por
premissa mostrar todos os lados e pra
mim silva demonstrado lado de israel era
hora de mostrar o lado libanês
eu estava na fronteira no mundo justo no
mundo racional bastava cruzar alguns dar
alguns passos cruzar a fronteira chegar
lá no líbano mas infelizmente nós não
vivemos num mundo justo nem no mundo
racional
eu descobri isso nas 24 horas seguintes
as fronteiras foram criadas pelos seres
humanos
muitas vezes a facão dividindo famílias
amigos e territórios etnias e povos
também eu voltei para a tela viva eu não
conseguir passar pela fronteira voltei
pra tela viva e então fui até a
embaixada do da cia perdão da jordânia
para voltar pra tentar um visto para
entrar na jordânia conseguiu o visto foi
da jordânia
cheguei na jordânia embaixada da síria e
pedir um visto para a embaixada da síria
aí todo brasileiro quando vai o exterior
sabe que houve aquelas pegadinhas não
funcionaram em recebê-la brasileiro e
tal
romário ronaldinho futebol é uma coisa
toda é bem simpática saiu quando voltou
tanto não vai entrar na síria como não
esteve em israel parece um pecado esteve
em israel e nenhum ninguém que visita
israel pode entrar num país inimigo da
síria
eu voltei pro hotel chorei
obviamente a minha cobertura de acabado
e eu sei que eu posso fazer quem sabe um
passaporte novo vou fazer isso
fui rebaixado brasil conseguiu
passaporte novo e voltei na embaixada da
cia torcendo para que a mulher que ela
não tivesse mais lá né
adivinha-se ao chegar lá quem e
atenderia a moça que ela simpática as
mesmas piadinhas brasil romário
ronaldinho tal pelé
ela olhou na minha cara estava me
escondendo que no mercado mas já teve
aqui
agora mesmo que tu não vai entrar no
hotel chorei mais um pouco e pensei que
eu vou fazer voltar à turquia
tudo isso em 24 horas a turquia cheguei
lá passaporte novo né
me deram um visto de viagem então pra
damasco na síria entrou de carro no
líbano eo meu objetivo então era aí ao
extremo sul do líbano para mostrar
aquela região do outro lado da fronteira
onde ela havia estado lá chegando em
cana que é uma cidadezinha bem no sul do
líbano
surpreendentemente não havia quem
entrevistar todas as pessoas têm fugido
ou tinham morrido num prédio morreram 19
mulheres e crianças jornalistas
normalmente bem eu tenho medo de
fronteiras
eu tenho medo de fronteiras porque elas
limitam de certa forma as definem aquilo
que o sucesso ou fracasso da minha
cobertura porque não entrou não consigo
fazer a cobertura e mas eu tenho sorte
porque jornalistas normalmente têm sorte
jornalistas conseguem entrar e sair e
estão lá porque querem não tem sorte é
as pessoas que estão aí não podem sair
e essas pessoas que não podem sair são
as verdadeiras vítimas
em 2005 o furacão katrina nos estados
unidos a impressão que eu tinha era de
que aquelas cenas de filme furacão vem
vindo as pessoas estão saindo tentando
sair está tentando entrar jornalistas
são assim tarde onde as pessoas estão
tentando sair então diz mil e oitocentas
pessoas haviam morrido naquela tragédia
dentro dos estados unidos uma guerra
dentro do território americano a maioria
das pessoas mortas eram mulheres negras
e pobres em 2010 terremoto no haiti 300
mil mortos
os 300 mil mortos é onde eu olhava
corpos nas ruas no calor do caribe
e aí tinha uma fronteira entre a
república dominicana eo haiti que era um
portão um portão enferrujado portão
enferrujado que esse aí que vocês estão
vendo separava o horror a morte a 300
mil pessoas mortas da república
dominicana guerra pelas mãos da natureza
ea paz
a primeira imagem que eu vi ao
transpassar e se essa fronteira era de
da polícia nacional haitiana reprimindo
os haitianos que tentavam fugir daquele
horror
a segunda imagem porque fronteira são
contrastantes era esse lago azul lindo
ea terceira imagem era horror
eu olho pra trás uma hora eu vejo uma
mulher é o partido dos parte da perna
dela estava descoberta uma mulher
haitiana negra e ela tinha as unhas
pintadas de rosa ela deixava o país dela
traz uma caminhonete na caçamba morta
as pessoas me perguntam por que nós
fazemos isso porque a gente deixa o
nosso lar
os nossos amigos a nossa mulheres nossa
mãe nossos pais nossos filhos irmãos
amigos nossos churrasquinho de final de
semana para ir ver isso aqui e eu
acredito que a gente faz isso justamente
porque eu - eu acredito certa forma ao
contar o drama que está acontecendo do
lado de lá eu vou sensibilizar alguém do
lado de cá é uma forma que eu tenho de
diminuir ou acabar com as fronteiras e
quem sabe unir mundos tão diferentes
nós nos orgulhamos de no século 20
termos chegado à lua termos de certa
forma erradicado muitas das doenças
nós nos orgulhamos até de estarmos
vivendo mais
em 1900 em londres uma pessoa que nasce
naquela época vivia no máximo até os 46
anos em 1990
tinha expectativa de vida em londres de
76 anos então é para se orgulhar mesmo
mas ao mesmo tempo no século 20 nós
matamos como nunca antes havíamos nos
matado como humanidade ao longo da
história do século 20 nós nos tornamos
muito mais cada vez mais lobos de nós
próprios
no século 20 nós derrubamos um muro de
berlim mas nós construímos outros muros
no lugar
puros como esse aí entre israelenses e
palestinos
muros como esse aí entre o méxico e os
estados unidos
muros dentro dos estados unidos de
miséria muitas vezes que a gente
desconhece
erguemos outras barreiras na europa
dentro do brasil na áfrica no mar
mediterrâneo
erguemos muros barreiras novas
fronteiras invisíveis e algumas
invisíveis de intolerância e preconceito
e medo barreiras que ainda hoje no
século 21 são intransponíveis isso meus
caros não pode terminar em pizza
obrigado
[Aplausos]